Let's construct the route for
our new menu item.
Now when I visit /restaurant and
pass in an integer, and then /new,
this integer will get passed in as the
new restaurant_id for the newMenuItem
function and successfully return
that task one is complete.
The editMenuItem takes
in two parameters, so
we need to make sure our route also has
two parameters, the restaurant_id and
the menu_id and then /edit.
Now, we'll see that
this page also works.
Similarly to the edit route,
the delete route looks just about
the same except it has /delete.
Now our final route is also working.
The solutions for this challenge
are available in the instructor notes.